wie kann aus meinung sagen und aus
anderer meinung seien plötzlich gewalt
werden
das ist anscheinend auch durch diese
radikalisierung durch das netz mit
befördert durch die sozialen medien ein
zum teil kleiner schritt der dann nur
noch gegangen wird und das kann ein ganz
klein auslöser haben also zum beispiel
lockdown zweig maßnahmen alle
ungeimpften kommen und wohin oder
brauchen
test wo sie nicht wissen wo sie denn her
bekommen sollen kann dazu führen dass
wieder mehr bürger sagen das mache ich
jetzt nicht mehr mit ich gehe auf die
straße das sind aber nicht die
extremisten und radikalen die uns jetzt
hier alle in dieser runde sorgen machen
ich denke wenn man dann die
größenordnungen sieht dann gibt's ja
diese laufenden untersuchungen der uni
konstanz das ungefähr 20 prozent in
deutschland die stores kritik am staat
im zusammenhang mit pandemie haben und
es ist davon nur noch wieder eine
minderheit die auf die straße geht habe
ich glaube es sind zwei dinge notwendig
einmal den muss eine klare kante gezeigt
werden wo ist die grenze dessen was der
rechtsstaat auch zulässt das ist schon
bei meinungsfreiheit bei sich versammeln
regeln einhalten das ist für die polizei
eine schwierige aufgabe weil sie selbst
ja zum objekt von beschimpfungen bis
boko wie auch immer werden aber wenn die
merken da ist eine grenze des
rechtsstaats dann denke ich hat das eine
wirkung in so eine szene die kritik
äußert weil sie dann wissen da wird
reagiert wenn man aber meint ich teste
mal alles aus was geht es fällt ja
vielleicht ähnlich auf und es wird
ähnlich reagiert dann führt das noch
wieder mehr menschen dazu also es kann
eine kleine gruppe von denen die sagen
mir ist es egal wie es hier ist ich will
hier meine wut gewalt mäßig rauslassen
kann sehr viel sage ich mal unruhe in
unsere demokratie bringen und deshalb
fand ich an manchen städten sehr schön
am wochenende das ist ja auch die
gegendemos gegeben hat und das waren
teilweise sehr viel mehr als die die
jetzt da gehetzt haben gegen politiker
was übrigens seit einigen jahren und das
wird untersucht seit 2015 mit den
flüchtlingen die kamen da hat die gewalt
bedrohung beleidigung gegen politikern
politiker und besonders auch auf
kommunaler ebene
zugenommen wo dann auch diese drohung
ich weiß wo deine kinder sind ich weiß
wie die in die schule gehen manche dann
einfach gesagt haben ich kann das meiner
familie nicht zumuten also wir haben
hier mehr als nur jetzt am wochenende
diese fürchterlichen ausschreitungen
gegen politiker auch gericht holen peter
neumann dazu den kanten terrorexperten
der auch im team von armin laschet war
im wahlkampf und möglicherweise dann ja
innenminister sogar geworden wäre herr
neumann schönen guten abend bei bild wir
versuchen bis hin zu ergründen was ist
das schöne grün für eine gruppe da auf
der straße das hat herr berger gerade
aus grimma geschildert das hat herr
meyer jetzt geschildert nach seinen
informationen die er aus greiz hat
können sie sagen ob das vorboten
terroristische aktionen sind die wir
sehen dort auf der straße und vor allen
dingen aber auch im netz erleben mit
diesem morddrohung
also ich kann mir das durchaus
vorstellen
leider aber ich denke dass das noch eine
weile dauern wird ja momentan eine
ziemlich große szene überall in
deutschland die serum konsolidiert ist
es sind ganz unterschiedliche gruppen
mit dabei und es kommt auch darauf an wo
sie schauen also wenn sie in thüringen
oder sachsen schauen dann sehen sie
häufig das tatsächlich rechtsextreme
versuchen diese bewegung zu kapern sich
an ihre spitze zu setzen die eigene
anhängerschaft dadurch zu verbreitern
das ist aber nicht überall in
deutschland so ein großer teil der leute
die bei den demonstrationen mit
laufenden sind leute die mit politik
noch gar nichts zu tun gehabt haben also
esoteriker homöopathen eindruck und so
von selbstverwaltung also nicht typische
rechtsextreme ich denke das wird sich in
den letzten oder in den nächsten monaten
zeigen was daraus entsteht meine
befürchtung ist dass die bewegung
insgesamt zwar kleiner wird dass sich
leute von dieser bewegung absetzen
werden aber dass die die übrig bleiben
sich weiter radikalisieren und auch eben
für gewalt eintreten wollen